the countdown is on for one of the
biggest Royal events in 70 years the
king's coronation and we've got all the
info you need
[Music]
also coming up we'll be investigating
exactly what a king does and how he and
the Prime Minister get on you know when
I have these conversations with him uh I
can see just how unbelievably committed
he is to serving our country
[Music]
we meet one of the hundreds of children
that got a surprise invitation to the
coronation from the king I didn't
realize she could be invited for
sleeping attention but here we are
[Music]
hi there we've got the lowdown on the
coronation from our team of reporters
but what do we know about King Charles
well we've been looking through the
archives
born on November 14 1948 Charles Philip
Arthur George was Queen Elizabeth's
first child so he became next in line to
the throne
Polo was one of his favorite sports and
he played it for many years
he also liked acting most exciting most
exciting news in Japanese quite like it
before I think I got quite a lot on here
it's very very large indeed
and he's visited the set of EastEnders
he also made a guest appearance on you
guessed it Coronation Street
by his early twenties the Prince of
Wales was amongst the first to speak out
about climate change
spent so much of my life trying to warn
that we have to operate in ways which
Make nature Thrive not suffer
in fact he introduced a sky kids
award-winning documentary about the
future of our planet
in this film we will be hearing from six
young climate activists from six
different continents
he married a 19 year old Nursery teacher
Lady Diana Spencer in 1981. they had two
sons Prince William and Harry
by the early 90s the couple were facing
difficulties in their marriage and later
divorced in 1996.
in 1997 Princess Diana died in a car
accident
it was a difficult time for the whole
country the royal family and especially
the princes
[Music]
nearly 10 years later happier times for
The King when he married his long-term
partner Camilla
they will now be known as King Charles
III and queen Camilla
[Music]
was watching lots of changes already a
new crown emoji has been created of the
Saint Edward's Crown which would be used
for the coronation
stamps have already been changed and
coins too the Royal Mint has released a
range of limited edition coins to Mark
the coronation
the final stage to truly welcome my new
king is his coronation so to get an idea
of what that will be like check out this
footage
Queen Elizabeth's coronation was the
first to be televised over to Maya in
London where she's getting more details
sojouria that coronation was watched by
277 million people across the globe 70
years on just as many will see King
Charles and queen Camilla leave
Buckingham Palace and make their way
through London in this stunning
horse-drawn carriage and this is mine
hi Emma
known as the king's procession more than
6 000 members of the Armed Forces follow
the king and queen consort as they make
their way to Westminster Abbey where the
coronation is being held
correspondent Laura bundock who were
reporting on the events of the day and
I'm off to meet her
the coronation is a big religious event
basically so what we'll see happen is
the king will take three Oaths he will
then go off and we won't see this but to
be anointed so that basically means he
will get holy oil put on him and it's
meant to be so sacred that the cameras
won't show this bit after the anointing
he will then come back and be presented
with various bits of Coronation regalia
they're all the sacred objects that
symbolize the roles and responsibilities
of the monarchy and including at the
moment we're all probably waiting for is
his crowning so this Edwards Crown will
be placed on his head and that's a
really big moment in the coronation
[Music]
so what happens back at the palace so
after the coronation finishes there's
going to be What's called the coronation
procession and that will take in the
gold State coach the king and the queen
because we'll call Camilla Queen after
the coronation all the way back from the
Abbey to Buckingham Palace there'll be a
welcome by the Army for for the king
there and then they'll head up onto the
Buckingham Palace balcony and then we'll
have a fly pass that will go over
Buckingham Palace to Mark the end of the
big day
[Music]
and even if you can't get a seat a TVs
and tablets will give us the best view
possible we're being asked to celebrate
with traditional British Street parties
just like we would have done 70 years
ago
there'll be huge screen set up in cities
and towns across the country to watch
the coronation and when Braden and I
interviewed the Prime Minister recently
it seemed it was the concert and Street
parties that he was most looking forward
to
you know I get to meet um his majesty
the king every week and we have a
meeting every week it's called an
audience that's your relationship like
do you guys get on to your mates yeah
yeah well I said I have I say well I'm
the Prime Minister he's uh he's the king
but I tell you one thing is you know
when I have these conversations with him
uh I can see just how unbelievably
committed he is to serving our country
and you know his strong desire to
represent everybody you know from every
Walk of Life and it's a real privilege
to be able to have that opportunity
every week and we're lucky to have him
and
um doing that job and when it comes to
coronation it's going to be an amazing
celebration it's going to be a great
celebration of our history but it's also
going to be a celebration of what's
coming in the future and what the king
is going to do now I'm I'm really
excited about the concert you guys
excited about the concert because that's
the best thing that's the best bit
oh that's about the bits I have to do as
well I think I'm looking forward to the
concert
um because Katy Perry is coming
um so that's that's on Saturday night
and then also we're having a big lunch
so I don't know are you guys having a
lunch out somewhere Street party or
something yeah I do like a lunch I do
like my food you like food yeah exciting
yeah so we're doing one on Downing
Street that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool so we're gonna have a big one so we
need it we need the weather to be right
but I think it's going to be it's going
to be a great weekend for the country
we're all just going to celebrate you
know this is a really special moment for
us and it's a great moment for us to
come together
foreign
[Music]
watching check this out was Victoria
sponge named after Queen Victoria and
was coronation chicken named after Queen
Elizabeth's coronation
um I might
coronation but I'm not too sure about
Victoria
and now there's a new coronation themed
dish coronation quiche and here's one I
prepared earlier so should give it a try
yeah but what's actually in it okay so
there's broad beans and spinach and
cheese and tarragon and obviously egg
okay so should we try it okay
hmm it's pretty good
[Music]
well this is the invite all the guests
receive from Buckingham Palace at the
bottom of the invitation you can see the
folklore figure of the Green Man to
affect the king's many years of
environmental campaigning King Charles
has surprised hundreds of children
community Heroes and charity workers
with an invited coronation including the
boy in the tent remember Max Weezy he
raised more than 750 000 pounds for
charity by spending three years in the
tent in his garden I could never do that
Scarlet could you that would be so
difficult he was a big inspiration to
Nate an FYI News Club member from
cotwood school in North Devon who
followed Max's blog so we asked him to
report for FYI on Max's invite to the
coronation from the beginning of his
challenge we followed the incredible
story of Max AKA temp boy hi I'm Max I'm
camping outside to raise money for the
northern hospice quite windy tonight
wow after three years of sleeping in his
tent Max has finally decided to move
back into to his family home hey Max
it's Bear Grylls here media and
celebrities all over the country have
admired matches determination and
fundraising skills and now he has
received the ultimate recognition how do
you feel when you received the
invitation to the coronation it was a
huge honor to be invited to the
coronation I didn't realize she could be
invited for sleeping urgent but here we
are did you ever want to give up it'd be
quite uncomfortable sleeping in the tent
a lot of rain and water would get into
it and it wasn't the nicest place to
live in but
knowing all the money was going to the
North End hospice I need I couldn't stop
there let's talk about the big day what
are you gonna wear can you show me you
know what give me two sacks
[Music]
oh
there you go
this should be it for the coronation wow
who are you going to the coronation with
so me and my dad are getting together
and we're hoping it can be a bit of the
boys trip just us too I think we have to
be up about six to arrive at I know it's
gonna be an early morning but I think we
have to get to the actual place at about
seven in the morning wow that I wouldn't
even be awake at that time I know it's
not going to be fun what bit are you
most looking forward to with the
coronation you know what just being able
to go there for the experience and it's
going to be a huge part of history and
it's going to be amazing just to be able
to say oh I was there I was there in the
actual event
[Music]
King Charles has supported hundreds of
Charities but he also set up his own the
prince's trust which helps young people
get into jobs Education and Training so
this got us thinking we know the royal
family opens new buildings and supports
loads of Charities but there's got to be
more to it than that yeah I mean the
kings are head of state but what powers
does he actually have until she passed
away Queen Elizabeth was all we our
parents and our grandparents had known
over the last few months we've had to
get used to having a King Charles III
the Monarch is also the head of state
but confusingly that doesn't mean he has
the most power
[Music]
Brayden has been on a mission to get
more info I'm going to need a bit of
help getting the head around this and I
know just the person hello Braden hello
so how much power does the British
monarch actually have well the Monarch
is a really important figurehead here in
the UK but actually when it comes to
things like making laws it is largely a
ceremonial role for example the Monarch
every week has a private meeting with
the Prime Minister but it's not the
Monarch's responsibility to tell the
Prime Minister what to do they are there
to advise encourage and to warn they
have that very important role as well of
giving out honors to people who've been
doing good work up and down the country
and carrying out visits to shine a light
on important Community projects now the
Monarch is also commander-in-chief of
the Armed Forces but it doesn't mean
it's their responsibility to start wars
that comes down to the UK government
which of course is voted for by UK
adults as part of our democracy well
thank you very much okay so I get all of
that but what I'm really scratching your
head about is how all this royal family
stuff even started so I'm gonna take us
back in time for a quick history lesson
that's right
you've heard of 1066 right that was the
year the French invaded England in what
was called the Norman Conquest having
won the battle this guy William the
Conqueror was made King of England even
though he could hardly speak in English
then there have been loads of battles
over who has control of the throne and
some untimely deaths so lots of
different kings and queens some of my
favorites are Richard II who was only 10
when he was crowned imagine that Henry
VIII who had Six Wives
and Elizabeth the first who fought off
an attempt to overthrow her when the
Spanish Armada sailed towards England
so the rules are that to become our head
of state you have to be born into the
royal family you also have to be
Christian because ever since the reign
of Henry VII part of the role is to be
the defender of the faith
the British monarch is the Supreme
governor of the Church of England but
they also recognize and celebrate all
the Fates
as for other countries well they all
have their own systems to decide who
becomes their head of state for example
in Saudi Arabia King Salman bin
abdulaziz has absolute power and there's
never been a national election
and in countries like the USA Brazil and
Nigeria the head of state is the
president elected by the people with
power to run the country and make new
laws
the system here in the UK is not without
its critics who say it's outdated and
too expensive but others argue that we
really benefit from having the monarchy
it allows the politicians to get on with
running the country without too many
distractions and having a royal family
with all its Traditions makes the UK
stand out in the world
thanks Brayden well that's all the info
we've got for you we're going to leave
you with some great messages from FYI
news club members for the king bye we
want to thank you and wish you a long
and glorious rain we hope you enjoyed
the coronation we will also be
celebrating two of our Scout group I
love your decision of Coronation food I
love quiche and I love spinach I also
look forward to eating the quiche it
will be delicious Charles I hope you
enjoy becoming the king and having a
nice time with your family and
everything goes exactly to plan I
appreciate how hard your job is and I
hope you still have fun despite the
responsibility I think it would be a
good King because of your act of
kindness I know the king's gonna be
great good luck we loved Queen Elizabeth
so we think he'll do just as great job
as your mother
foreign